Speaker 1: Let's go to Robert from
San Diego. Robert, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello. Hey, how are you?
Oh, you can hear me. Yes. Wow. Amazing.
I haven't I haven't it's been a long time. I tried
to be on the show. I'm just trying to be. I have.
First, I want to say that I have some mental
illness, some problems. I want to make you to
help me to make sure that I am calm and capable,
beautiful talking. You're doing great. Okay?
OK, first I started watching your program
sometime last year. I really admire it.
Your ability to stay calm and
collected is just amazing.
Thank you. Especially with people. You know all
these controversial figures. I just wanted to
give you my perspective a little and
have one little question for you.
I'm going to try to make it quick.
Speaker 1: Now, Robert, just
in the interest of time, and because your
discord is blinking up a storm, maybe for
today we could get right to the question.
Speaker 2: OK. Yes. Or my right to the question,
I have been watching Belarus for years and years
and years, and I've known it for now. I know I've
known what autocracy really is. My question for
you is how many? How many? How long do you think
Trumpist would like Trump to be president?
Speaker 1:
You know, I think it depends on which one year?
Speaker 2: Yeah. I mean, gosh,
Speaker 1: I think that there are Trumpists
who, if they thought Trump could keep winning,
would say there should be no term
limits on. They would say, Listen,
if we want to keep electing him, why shouldn't
he be allowed to just stay in the White House? I
don't think that applies to all Trumpists, though.
Speaker 2: So all of them? Yeah. Oh, OK. Well,
because with me watching that, I was I was
always wondering about and that I was thinking,
Oh my gosh, that would be a nightmare.
Speaker 1: No, you're completely right that there
are Trumpists who would say there's no reason for
term limits. We think Trump could keep winning,
and he should just stay in for as long as people
want him. Not all of them, but some of them.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. OK.
Speaker 1:
Robert, thank you for the call. I really
appreciate it, you've done a great job.
And let's hope to hear from more people in
the future that's going to do it for today.
As always, we can't ever take every call,
but we will take calls again very soon